autres photos c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment le parfait dalian mais je vais
faire tout de suite un enfant de stars
vous savez à les stars couchent ensemble
et ça fait et on retrouve leurs enfants
parce que là c'est vrai que cette
semaine c'est on n'a que la photo on n'a
pas la vidéo mais je tenais quand même
vraiment a voulu passer parce que ça
concerne l'équipe parce qu'on sait
qu'être belle saloperie même qui
cependant ne touche pas à mon pote et là
apparemment c'est gilles verdez et
isabelle maury le nord isabelle aurait
fait une danse endiablée agile et
apparemment ils ont commis l'irréparable
on a retrouvé la photo de leur fille on
l'a regardé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est dégueulasse
laprise quel côté ayant gagné plus
désobligeants
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est mal au dos ces photomontages c'est
à dire que cette personne vie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa télé fait mais l'enfer elle même mais
je m'en derrière photo montage break
c'est vraiment le parfait alliage des
d'isabelle et chanter la photo apparaît
pied à les maxima pas pourquoi la gauche
ne bat pas vraiment mais c'est elle et
pas du tout l est pas français je suis
sûr essayer de la faire venir mais là je
la connais pas g
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez-vous camille aller chercher toute
la télévision française
car lorsque ma télé allumée c'est comme
quand je me retrouve dans la même pièce
que cyril je ne peux pas détourner mes
yeux de lui
[Musique]